quanto costa essere felici
io sono cresciuto con l'idea che per
realizzarsi per essere felici
bisogna in qualche modo guadagnare tanti
soldi
forse perché la società ci ha un po il
posto dei modelli di persone di successo
in qualche modo il nono successo hanno
costruito anche grazie al fatto di aver
fatto i soldi
io sono stato da sempre fissato sul bene
e ho sempre pensato appunto che per
essere xvi è dovuto in qualche modo fare
tanti soldi pensate che fibra elementari
la mattina andavo a scuola
una macchinina è l'obiettivo della mia
giornata era
scambiare barattare questa macchina con
qualcosa che avesse un valore maggiore
l'altro giocattolo piuttosto che una
maglietta
mi piaceva chiamare questo gioco il
gioco degli affari e mi veniva anche
bene ea fine giornata quando avevano
incrementato il valore del mio
patrimonio in qualche modo è una rosa
efficiente e
dopo qualche tempo ho scoperto che a
milano a pochi passi da piazza duomo
esistevano un luogo dove gli adulti
giocavano al mio stesso gioco degli
affari solamente che non lo facevano
chiaramente con le macchinine ma non
facevano piccoli pezzettini di società
in azioni con luogo era la borsa la
borsa di milano
e se non sapete come funziona me lo
spiego è semplicissimo se avete un
azienda che ha un buon prodotto un buon
fatturato e volete fare in modo che
questa azienda cresca
se andate in borsa si votate la vostra
azienda in borsa
molto semplicemente troverete delle
persone gli investitori che saranno
disposti a dargli del denaro in cambio
di un pezzettino piccolo pezzettino
della nostra società un'azione appunto
l'affiliata però è che questa azione
se l'azienda continua a crescere a
performare
crescerà di valore nel tempo cosa che
poi si traduce lina alcune console di
nelle nostre tasche
ha osservato le borse i mercati
finanziari per tanto tempo prima dal
televideo di canale5 tanti anni fa poi
nelle dettagli monitor le vetrine delle
banche
poi un animo di internet sono arrivate
le piattaforme di trading e tutto è
stata più semplice
e
[Musica]
dopo un po di anni pronti per un pronto
inosservato così tanto i mercati che
avevo deciso di lanciarlo in questa
attività e non so come ma un convinto i
miei genitori a prestar di 16 mila euro
a coppia l'impiegato quindi era una
cifra assolutamente di tutto rispetto
e il primo giorno di attività tra trader
così si chiama la persona che opera sui
mercati finanziari ho guadagnato 2 mila
euro ma ci franchi la bp
odiavi ero al settimo cielo perché
pensavo di aver trovato il modo di
raggiungere lo scopo
ma rimarrebbe essere xvi tramite denaro
e anche i miei genitori erano perché 2
mila euro era la stessa cifra che mio
padre al tempo guadagnava in un mese di
da uomo
a distanza di un mese ho perso tutto
0 sul conto non c'erano più soldi
e
oltre al conto andare in fumo sono
andati anche il mio sogno dei sogni di
diventare ricco e felice
centro però immune settimane in quel
momento che qualcuno mi raccontò la
storia del pescatore messicano
si racconta
che un giorno in questo villaggio di
pescatori
arriva un ricco imprenditore metano che
dopo ho incontrato e
mangiato
pesce
per chiedere quanto tempo adesso
impiegato per restare questo pc è stato
dice
sai tutto il resto della giornata ma
guarda gli asu tardi per sfruttandone
faccio una siesta con mia moglie il
pomeriggio gioco con l'ausilio e la sera
esco con gli amici avere un abile vetta
sono un po la chitarra che andare
qualche canzone
a quel punto l'imprenditore si eccita si
casa appunto gli dice guarda io sono un
imprenditore posso aiutarti posso fare
da consulente per te
toni una immensa continuità seduta
domani
cominciare il cane per tutto il giorno
nel giro di un po di tempo animali soldi
per permetterti una seconda barca e con
questa seconda barca potrai prendere
ancora più pesce e con i soldi extra che
farai potrai permetterti altre coppie
fino ad arrivare un intera svolta tutta
tua e non finisce qua perché una volta
che tu in una flotta tutta tua per
smettere di pesce al ventaglio
strali trasferirti magari a new york e
sono un accordo direttamente con la
grande distribuzione
e attivo immagine saliranno e potrai
guadagnare cosi tanto che il mondo per
metterti addirittura un impianto tutto
tuo di inscatolamento cosa che ti farà
fare alcuna più soldi il pescatore
rimane un attimo così e diceva che la
vittima
quanto tempo di brani geniali per
arrivare ad ottenere tutto questo ma
guarda a spanne
tempi 25 anni
pescatore ci pensa dice e dopo
l'imprenditore si sfrega le mani dice
dopo che nel bello perché
usare già new york ti sei già trasferito
a new york a quel punto avrebbero la tua
azienda avviata con tanti clienti con le
immagini incredibili e se la canterà in
borsa ci saranno un sacco di investitori
disposti a darti milioni di dollari per
comprare le azioni della tua azienda
ritmo di titolare in un veramente essi
così funziona loro i mercati finanziati
da corsa funziona così il pescatore
chiedendo una volta che ho venduto tutto
e con tutti i soliti avrei fatto potrai
ritirarti in un villaggio di pescatori
svegliati tardi la mattina pescare un
balcone
fare la siesta punto oggi pomeriggio a
giocare contro figli la sera uscire per
una birretta con i tuoi amici sono pro
la chitarra e cantare qualche canzone
so che questa strada e mi è piaciuta
conosco persone che dopo veniva sentita
se sono licenziate
se c'è una cosa che a me questa storia
mi ha cambiato nella vita e la vita
perché abbia fatto mi ha insegnato a
vedere il mondo da un punto di vista
completamente diverso e se c'è una cosa
che mi ha insegnato questa storia
e che
se davvero volevo fare i soldi non
dovevo concentrarmi su tali soldi ma sul
sale con passione
una cosa che amavo far
fare soldi in borsa un fan soldi borsa
non basta solo saper leggere un bilancio
o saper interpretare il grafico di
un'azione bisogna riuscire ad avere la
sensibilità di capire quando sarà
l'impatto che una determinata azienda
avrà sulla vita delle persone
maggiore sarà questo impatto e maggiore
sarà il successo di questa azienda avrà
nel suo futuro
so che ancora un party pensano che se
una persona ha fatto tanti soldi ho
avuto tanto successo in qualche modo lo
ha fatto sulle spalle delle altre
persone ma io non credo che sia così
se c'è qualcuno magari tra di voi che
pensa che mark zuckerberg per esempio
fondatore di facebook sia una sorta di
rettiliano
succube dei poteri forti
provate a immaginare come sarebbe stato
vivere la parte via senza walls atto
se ci sono tre cose che mi hanno
insegnato i mercati finanziari
e che per avere successo non possiamo
ragionare come singoli individui ma come
collettività
qualsiasi sia la nostra età qualsiasi
sia il nostro lavoro non dobbiamo
concentrarci su quello che stiamo
facendo
ma sul motivo per cui stiamo facendo
quella cosa e se nel vostro percorso
cominciamo ad aiutare anche le altre
persone non solo raggiungeremo il nostro
obiettivo con troveremo anche nella
felicità